hello and welcome to the chichi science
show where in this video we're going to
revisit
resveratrol and look at the latest data
showing the results of some recent
human trials whereby patients with
either heart failure or muscular
dystrophy
were treated with resveratrol now the
last time i spoke about resveratrol i
feel like i may have caused a little bit
of the stress
mainly because we looked at the
publication that suggested that
resveratrol could be inducing
replicative stress in cells
due to the effect that part of
resveratrol action seems to be by
inhibiting dna synthesis
but as i also mentioned near the end of
that video it seems to be that
considering the dose of resveratrol is
very important
for delineating its beneficial and
detrimental impacts for the body so
we'll be taking an extra close attention
to the doses used
in these two latest publications showing
some human data
whereby patients were taking resveratrol
to either alleviate symptoms of muscular
dystrophy
or heart disease so just quickly then
what actually is resveratrol
well resveratrol is a naturally
occurring phenylpropanoid that's found
in a variety of different foods
for example the skin of grapes
blueberries raspberries and also in
peanuts
and resveratrol is a phytoelectron which
means that it's produced by plants when
under stressful conditions
such as being infected by pathogens or
being physically harmed
so what does resveratrol actually do
well there's a lot of hype surrounding
resveratrol as it's been shown that
it can extend lifespan in a variety of
different model organisms
such as yeast worms fruit flies as well
as mice when fed on a high fat diet
however to get the same level of
resveratrol as performed in these
studies it's been calculated that you
would need to drink around 111
glasses of red wine so instead people
have looked to supplementation
but what is the actual mechanism behind
this apparent increase in lifespan
seen in the different model organisms
well it's thought that resveratrol acts
by
increasing the activity of the protein
set one
cert one comes from a family of proteins
known as sertoins that are
nad plus dependent enzymes that play
multiple roles within the cell
one of which seems to be activation of
stress resistance pathways
however the biochemical underpinning of
resveratrol isn't fully understood yet
nonetheless due to the connections
between resveratrol and
activation or stress resistance pathways
respiratory was being investigated to
see if it could be effective for
ameliorating
for a variety of different diseases so
this nicely brings us on to these two
recent papers
that give the results of some human
trials but by their uterus ferrotroll to
ameliorate the symptoms of either heart
failure
or muscular dystrophy so let's just
begin with
this first study resveratrol improves
heart function
by moderating inflammatory processes in
patients with systolic heart failure
now the prevalence of heart failure is
continuing to rise throughout the world
however previous work has shown that
resveratrol supplementation
in rodent models prevented the
development of heart failure
when their heart muscles had been
damaged however until this publication
the impact of resveratrol on human
patients with heart failure had yet to
be assessed
so in this study they performed a
double-blind randomized
placebo-controlled study
whereby 30 patients were assigned
resveratrol and 30 patients were given a
placebo
and the dose of resveratrol that the
patients were given were
two 50 mg capsules so they were taking
100 milligrams of resveratrol per day
and they did this for three months
and just to clarify all of the patients
had heart failure with reduced ejection
fraction
and so a variety of different
measurements were taken before and after
the three months of treatment
one of the significant differences was a
reduction in the level of two
inflammatory cytokines
interleukin-1 and interleukin-6 moreover
there was a reduction in galectin-3
which is often used as a biomarker for
heart failure and more strikingly they
saw that
the left ventricular ejection fraction
also significantly increased in the
group given resveratrol
suggesting that there seems to be
improvements in their heart performance
as this also correlated with an increase
in the six minute walk distance in the
respiratory group
so the results from this study seem
pretty promising for the use of
resveratrol
in systolic heart failure patients as an
addition to the standard therapy
however as the authors also note there
are a few limitations
firstly the low number of enrolled
patients being only 30 given resveratrol
and also the relatively short follow-up
periods so if these two things can be
improved
it would be much more convincing to
prove the efficacy of resveratrol
supplementation
in systolic heart failure as well as to
maybe try and better understand the
exact biochemical and cellular mechanism
by looking at more biomarkers so let's
now take a look at the second
publication
resveratrol improves motor function in
patients with muscular dystrophies
so as stated in the title this is a
phase 2a study
and these are typically very small
clinical trials
and that's pretty evident in this study
where they only had 11 patients
and the patients had either dot chen
becca or fukuyama muscular dystrophy
and in comparison to the heart failure
study where they were taking
100 milligrams per day here they
initially started taking 500 milligrams
a day
which was then increased every eight
weeks to a thousand milligrams
to 1500 milligrams or 1.5 grams per day
so the key differences so far well is
firstly obviously the different diseases
but secondly there is a much lower
number of patients in the muscular
dystrophy trial
however they were using a higher dose
and they also did it for a longer time
period
here doing it for 24 weeks which is
around six months in comparison to the
three months study in the heart failure
trial
and so muscular dystrophies are
inherited disorders that are
characterized by
progressive muscle weakness and
disability so in this study they were
looking
primarily to see what impact resveratrol
had
on motor function and they did this by
looking at the motor function measure
scale
muscular strength monitored by muscle
testing and also by looking at the serum
creatine kinase levels
and interestingly as a secondary outcome
they also wanted to look at the
tolerability
of resveratrol and if there are any
adverse effects
and one of the reasons they decided to
use resveratrol is
a previous study found that cert 1
overexpression
so cert 1 being a protein that
resveratrol was thought to activate
in the skeletal muscles of mdx mice
which are an animal model of doctrine
muscular dystrophy
decrease the serum creatine kinase
levels tissue fibrosis and myofibril
damage
and increases their ability to run long
distances compared to the control mice
so what about in humans then well they
found that the mean
motor function measure score increased
significantly after 24 weeks of
medication
and they also found a twofold increase
in the mean
quantitative muscle testing scores and
also they found the mean
creating kinase levels decreased
considerably by around 34
now i've emphasized the word mean
because there is quite
a bit of variation between the different
patients
however more interestingly in their
study they found that diarrhea and
abdominal pain was noted in six and
three patients respectively
and this resulted in some of them
reducing their dose from
1.5 grams per day down to 1 gram per day
and so i think the study highlights
again the importance of really trying to
understand the impact of dose
on the impact that it has on cells which
was more of the point i was trying to
make in my previous video
and so obviously from a study like this
where it was only done in 11 patients
it is still really hard to take any
significance from it
nonetheless this does show great
potential for using resveratrol for
ameliorating the symptoms of muscular
dystrophy
and i guess trying to bring the two
trials together this is kind of the
the main point of these early stage
trials is just to see
the primary outcome in terms of
ameliorating
impacts of the disease by the treatment
and to see if there's any consequences
or any side effects to taking the drugs
and so i think definitely
dose is really important when it comes
to resveratrol
and it would be nicer now to see these
clinical trials
expand and do it for longer time periods
to really see
the long-term impact on resveratrol
supplementation so hopefully this video
has given you a good overview if not
brief
to the different trials i've linked down
the papers in the description
and so i hope you found something and as
always thanks for listening